IKAI LAN: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to Google "Apps
Script Office Hours"
for November 9, 2012.
My name Ikai Lan.
ERIC KOLEDA: And I'm
Eric Koleda.
IKAI LAN: And we've got a great
"Office Hours" show for
you, today.
ERIC KOLEDA: Just like
every "Office Hours."
IKAI LAN: Every "Office Hours"
we have is top notch.
So we've got a couple of
interesting things to announce.
First off, I'll start by
announcing that we-- wow,
we're actually starting
to fill for
the Los Angeles Hackathon.
I think there's not that
many spaces left.
So if you get a chance and
you're in the Los Angeles, do
come check us out.
You can search for the Hackathon
site at Google Apps
Script Los Angeles Hackathon.
It was actually easier to say
that whole thing than to read
out the URL, which is actually
really long.
So go ahead and sign up.
Let us know if you're coming.
We'd love to meet you and hear
about what you're doing, and
help you come up with ideas
for trying to solve your
workflow problems, and just
automating things you're doing
with Google Apps.
ERIC KOLEDA: So maybe for some
people that haven't been at a
Google Hackathon before,
can you run us
through what happens?
IKAI LAN: Oh, yeah, sure.
See?
I just assumed that everyone's
been to a Hackathon.
So what we're going to do is
we're hosted at the Google Los
Angeles office across
from Venice Beach.
ERIC KOLEDA: Ooh.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, you know,
get to the chopper.
That's the worst Arnold
impression.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to lead you guys
through a tutorial of how to do
a sign-up sheet via Google
Forms and Google Spreadsheets.
We're going to talk about some
of the things that people use
Apps Script for.
We're going to try to organize
you into teams, but we don't
necessarily have
a competition.
We just want everyone to have
a good time and learn some
stuff about Apps Script.
Now, I'd say about half the
people use the time to hack
and try to build new products or
new tools and new scripts.
Whereas the other half, what
they do is they like to run
through tutorials.
And it's a very good time to do
tutorials as well, because
we'll be there to help you if
you run into any problems and
answer any questions you have.
Now, obviously what we want is
for you to build products.
And what people end up doing
is they end up looking up
tutorials and saying, well, I
need to do something very,
very similar to this.
So first I'm going to do a
tutorial, then I'm going to go
ahead and adopt something, so
I'm going to turn this into
something I would
use everyday.
What is this guy?
What's happening over here?
That goes on the
outtakes video.
We're making an outtake.
ERIC KOLEDA: We're good.
IKAI LAN: That would be good.
Anyway, so a good example is
someone came last time and he
did our chart tutorial,
and he merged it
with his own invoices.
He keeps Invoices for his
clients in Google
Spreadsheets.
So he wrote a script that goes
through his Google Drive,
looks for all the invoices,
and charts how
much money he's making.
So it was kind of funny because
he demoed it, and he
demoed with his live data, and
he showed us all the money he
was making or wasn't making
at certain times.
And that was kind of funny.
ERIC KOLEDA: It was
very open of him.
IKAI LAN: He's an open guy.
I liked him.
ERIC KOLEDA: It was good, but
I think he had like what?
Maybe five, six hours
of hacking in there.
It depends, I guess, on how late
you stay in the night,
but some time to hack.
So it's hard to go all
the way from idea to
fully polished app.
So using the tutorials or
working in a team is a way to
speed up the process, and get
further, and explore more
rather than just going solo
or something like that.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, it's really
going to be a lot of fun.
We love talking to people.
And we will have food.
I think last time we had pizza,
and this time we will
have pizza and also a healthier
option, which is we
will have Mediterranean food--
if things go to plan.
But I can't guarantee that.
I can't guarantee the we'll
have that available.
So it might change at the last
minute depending on our needs.
ERIC KOLEDA: Sign up now,
I guess, right?
IKAI LAN: Yeah, sign up now.
We still have a couple spots.
We have a lot of sign-ups
the last few days.
It's going to be a really
packed event.
I'm really looking
forward to this.
ERIC KOLEDA: Killer.
IKAI LAN: We've got a couple
of other things we want to
talk about today.
So hold on real quick while
I log into my laptop.
So we're going to talk about
the Release Notes.
Some good stuff has
been pushed out.
We've got two recent
blog posts that we
just want to highlight.
Eric's going to help us
highlight these things.
And we're going to talk about
Google Cloud SQL a little bit.
The Cloud SQL is a product that
we have that allows you
to create hosted SQL databases
that you can use in your
applications.
You could access it via Google
App Engine, but now you'll be
able to access your Google Cloud
SQL via Apps Script,
which gives you yet another
persistence option.
So we'll talk a little bit about
that before we head to
the live Q&A and discussion.
ERIC KOLEDA: Sounds good.
IKAI LAN: Sound good?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
IKAI LAN: So why don't
we start by talking--
do you want to do release notes
first, or do you want to
do the recent blog
posts first?
ERIC KOLEDA: Let's
do blog posts.
IKAI LAN: OK, let's do blog--
that makes sense.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah,
all right so this
week, we had our election.
But the week prior, we--
IKAI LAN: We had an election.
This is true.
ERIC KOLEDA: We had
an election.
And the week prior, we put out
some blog posts that were
election themed just in
time for the season.
So the first of which is that
here on the Apps Script
Developer Relations team, we put
together a sample app that
uses Apps Script to build a web
application that connects
to the Google Civic
Information API.
This is an API that Google
provided that allows you to
query for a given address--
where do I go vote?
How late are they open?
What's the address?
Who are the candidates?
So we use that API to build this
sample web application.
Because we think of this
kind of scope, right?
Having a data source that's JSON
based, that's publicly
accessible, and serving that
in a web format that
integrates with your Google
properties is really the
strong point of Google
Apps Script.
So this sample application
created a calendar event for
election day.
It saved to Drive information
about where to go vote or even
send you an email for the
details of where to go vote.
And It was a really cool
sample app that we had
[? Calian ?]
on our team and Arun
put together.
And I think they turned
out pretty great.
IKAI LAN: Where are
those guys now?
ERIC KOLEDA: Where
are they now?
IKAI LAN: Yeah, they're
never here.
I'm just kidding.
[? Calian's helping ?] helping
us produce this show, and he's
like giving me the evil
eye right now.
And Arun, I think he's
at an event, right?
At that your cause, I believe?
ERIC KOLEDA: I think so.
He'll probably report
back next week.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, that
would make sense.
So there's a second sample
app as well.
I remember using this
application, and it's funny
when you're working with
applications that aren't fully
developed yet.
And they asked us to test
their app, and I do it.
And I'm like, how come
it says my polling
place is North Carolina?
And they go, oh, we only have
one polling place in the
database right now.
So I'm like, oh, right,
well, otherwise, it
works pretty well.
ERIC KOLEDA: Test data.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, test data.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, so that
was one blog post we did.
And then we did a second one
where we actually have another
Googler named Chris Cartland.
IKAI LAN: So a funny story
about Chris Cartland.
We always laugh about this.
In our employee directory, you
can set the name you want to
be called as.
So he likes being known
as Cartland.
So inside the employee
directory, it says his name is
Cartland Cartland.
So we we're arguing about
whether or not that was his
birth name.
ERIC KOLEDA: No.
Chris Cartland.
IKAI LAN: Yes, his name
is Chris Cartland
ERIC KOLEDA: Officially.
IKAI LAN: But he likes to
be called Cartland.
ERIC KOLEDA: So Cartland put
together this cool script,
actually back when he was at
university, for doing voting.
So there are a lot of
different types of
voting in the world.
The ones that we use for
elections here in the United
States is majority
wins, right?
But there are a lot of other
more complex types.
And the one that he wanted to
use was this one called
instant run-off voting.
It's basically a system where
instead of just selecting one
person that you want to vote
for, you give an ordered list
of who you'd like to vote for.
And if the first person on your
list isn't going to come
close to winning, they scratch
it off and then go to your
next choice.
So it's kind of a way to bring
in third parties or make it so
it's a different type of voting
that can in some case
work out better.
So he wanted to use that
for, I think, a
university club he was in.
So we wrote an Apps Script
that uses Google Forms to
collect the data, then put it
into a spreadsheet, and then
use Apps Script to process all
those results, do the voting
calculation, and then come
up with a winner.
Obviously, doing a more complex
voting scheme is
harder when you're
doing it by hand.
So we published a blog
post about that.
That's pretty great.
And he made that script
available in the script
gallery if you want to
try it out yourself.
IKAI LAN: He made
a video, too.
ERIC KOLEDA: And a
very nice video.
IKAI LAN: So you can look
for these if you go to
googleappsdevelo
per.blogspot.com.
Sometimes it's easier just to
go into your favorite search
engine and search for Google
Apps Developer blog, and
you'll find it.
Now, notice that I don't
plug Google there.
Because people might have a
different search engine.
Like I have my own
search engine.
It's called "Ikai's Super
Search Engine."
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh, I
have to try that.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, it's in
stealth right now.
Also the results are static.
OK, it's a Python web app with
a dictionary that directly
maps your query string
to a URL.
ERIC KOLEDA: Sounds scalable.
IKAI LAN: Don't you have
somewhere to be?
Just kidding.
We have a lot of fun on this
team, as you can tell.
So why don't we go ahead and
move into the release notes?
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, man,
did we have a lot of
release notes recently.
IKAI LAN: Did we?
I mean, did you cover the
October 26 stuff or--
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, so the
October 26 release kind of
happened right around Sandy.
IKAI LAN: Oh, yeah.
ERIC KOLEDA: So the hurricane
put that one on delay.
It did not get out until
early this week.
I think on Monday is when
I got it out there.
IKAI LAN: Well, hold
on for a second.
Why don't we share a
screen real quick.
You know, I just realized
something.
I didn't plug it in.
We we're just talking
about this.
That goes on a blooper reel.
So why don't we just go ahead
and do this without the
screensharing then.
It'll probably still be
just as effective.
So let's start October 26.
I was caught in a hurricane, as
were you and [? Calian, ?]
although I think
you had power.
ERIC KOLEDA: I had power.
I just did not have connection
to the Google server.
So I couldn't log in and
get this published out.
IKAI LAN: You had power
but no laptop.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yep.
IKAI LAN: I had a laptop
but no power.
So it's like together, we have
formed a useful person.
But we did not do that.
It's like Voltron.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, and
I was thinking of
Voltron in my head.
IKAI LAN: So on October 26, we
pushed out a release where we
fixed a ton of bugs.
But there's two big things I
want to talk about here which
are, one is that we pushed out
a class Gmail attachment.
So prior to this, one of the
common use cases for Apps
Script was to write scripts
that would go through your
Gmail, look for, say, large
attachments, and say, hey, do
you want to delete
this, right?
It would at least list them on
a spreadsheet, maybe it'd
email it to you, maybe
you'd label it.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, so a
lot of apps like that.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
The problem with the script--
and I was writing one-- is
that you run into a quota
very quickly.
So there's a quota that you
hit that's really bad.
OK, well, our producer
is pointing at me.
And so we should really not--
the fourth wall, like
we're breaking it.
ERIC KOLEDA: You've got to
shield yourself there.
IKAI LAN: I know.
I'm sorry about the
interruption.
So now it's much easier to write
scripts that do that
because there's a new API called
getSize via the Gmail
attachment.
So call that instead of "get
attachments," I believe.
So hopefully, we can get out a
sample that can show you guys
how to write a script
like this.
ERIC KOLEDA: I think before,
people had to fetch all of the
bytes and then measure the
size of those bytes.
IKAI LAN: Yes, that
is what I did.
ERIC KOLEDA: Right.
And so instead of fetching the
bytes, which actually causes
us to do a lot of extra work, we
already have the total size
stored somewhere, so we can
just give you the size.
IKAI LAN: Right.
That was a very silly
way of doing things.
The more I thought about it, I
was like, I am reading all the
bytes of the attachment.
I don't care what's in the
attachment, right?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, yeah.
That's a cool improvement.
But then there's another
great Gmail
improvement there, too, right?
The top one here on
our release notes.
IKAI LAN: Oh, GetAliases.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, so this was
actually one of our most
highly rated feature requests.
I think it had in the hundreds
of stars on it, which is how
we measure how important an
issue is, which is the ability
to figure out-- you know
how in Gmail--
I don't know how many people
have set it up.
I have it set up for myself.
In Gmail you can send an email
as a different address.
IKAI LAN: Yes!
ERIC KOLEDA: There's an
authorization process, where
it sends you an email,
and you confirm it.
But then after that point, there
is a drop-down where you
can say, OK, send this email
address using this other
address that I own.
And that was never available
in Gmail App until now.
So with gmailapp.getaliases, you
can figure out all of the
aliases that you're
approved to use.
And then when you do that "send
mail," you can pass in
an extra "from" field that will
specify, "send as this
address."
IKAI LAN: That's a very useful
feature because you don't
always want to be sending
as yourself.
ERIC KOLEDA: Especially within
an organization.
Sometimes you're Gary, but you
want to send it as a more
official email address.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, sometimes I want
to send emails as Eric.
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, I'm not going
to approve that one.
IKAI LAN: Like, dear JP Morgan
Chase, please transfer--
lock your screen.
That's my warning to you.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's dangerous
to sit next to this guy.
But, yeah those are two really
great Gmail improvements that
came out during that release.
And there was some other small
stuff listed here.
IKAI LAN: Oh , that's right.
We did the JavaScript execution
performance stuff.
I totally forgot
about that one.
So we have a lot of really great
users that are always
benchmarking saying, hey, what's
going on with this.
And sometimes things are
going to be slower.
Sometimes it's going
to be faster.
But when things are like 1,000
times slower, that's usually
an indication that something's
not working correctly.
So we've addressed some
JavaScript execution things.
So if you're running things in
a very tightly loop, you'll
see some improvements there.
Now, granted, if you're making
lots of API calls, it's not
really going to have a big
impact because of the cost for
a round-trip API call, which is
why we've included batching
and things such as
spreadsheets--
ERIC KOLEDA: Right.
IKAI LAN: --to make
things speed up.
Now, an analogy i like to use
here is that sometimes-- and
you've seen me do this, where
I'll just eat a whole pizza.
And Eric, people have commented,
why are you eating
a whole pizza and drinking
Diet Coke?
And that's kind of what's
happening here, is that if you
increase your JavaScript
execution performance, but
you're still making tons of API
calls, you're not going to
get a lot of benefit there.
So this is going to be really
useful if you're doing lots of
typed calculations, but not
necessarily if you're making
lots of API calls.
ERIC KOLEDA: I never would
have thought that.
That actually would have made
sense, that analogy, but it
actually did.
So yeah, good to go.
IKAI LAN: Yeah!
ERIC KOLEDA: So, yeah,
doing math, right?
Doing loops, those kind of
things are going to be faster.
I think we saw a 3 to
4x improvement.
If you're calling out to fetch
data from a spreadsheet, that
has not been touched.
IKAI LAN: And what's
the last one?
The last improvement is we've
made a really big improvement
to how you can fetch files
from Google Drive.
So previously, you can only
fetch 2,000 items, which was
kind of bad.
ERIC KOLEDA: It sounds like a
lot, but with Drive and the
amount of storage you get
for free, that can
fill up pretty quick.
IKAI LAN: Now, there's a
new way of doing this.
So instead of saying, get
everything, what you want to
do, is you want to use this
"get files for paging,"
because what you get back
is a page token.
And every next iteration of the
call, you want to pass the
token to the method.
And this is really useful,
because now you have a
continuation, and you
can keep going.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, so this
allows you to do activities
people had wanted to do, like I
want to back up my drive, I
want to list everything
in my drive.
You couldn't do that before.
You couldn't get more
than 2,000.
So now you can't get all those
files in one go, right?
But at least now there's a way
by a page by page by page, and
you can work your way through
all the files.
IKAI LAN: And we've submitted
a bunch of bugs fixes.
So if you could check those out
by looking for Apps Script
Release Notes.
It's on our site just click
on Release Notes.
And that's October 26.
November 6, we also had a lot
of really great updates.
So we fixed a couple
of issues.
Oh, we updated icons.
That's a big deal.
But more importantly, we made
some cleanup changes.
One is to LockService.
We had a problem with the UI
Service where if you built a
UI app and called
LockService, it
wouldn't always work correctly.
In fact, I think it would work
correctly some of the time,
but not all the time.
ERIC KOLEDA: It was sporadic.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, so we've
addressed that.
So now you should be able to
use LockService service to
lock sections of you
code so you don't--
it's called erase condition,
where if you make a change,
and Eric makes a change, you can
lock something so he can't
overwrite my change in the
middle of my change.
Now, that doesn't mean he can't
come back later and just
undo my change.
ERIC KOLEDA: Right.
IKAI LAN: But at least you won't
get things in a weird
state, which is typically what
you want to use something like
LockService for.
Like let's say you had to modify
two things, right?
You want to edit a doc
and send an email.
And you made sure you wanted
those things to happen one
after the other, and
you didn't want
anything else to interrupt.
You can use LockService to get
a lock, and lock that so that
only one script can execute
that at any given time.
ERIC KOLEDA: If you're writing
a script just for yourself,
these problems don't come up.
But with an organization or a
script that maybe has even
broader usage, you could get two
people hitting the script
at almost the exact
same second, and
that could cause problems.
So the LockService, it's good
that that's back in action.
IKAI LAN: We've also added a
little bit of syntactical
sugar, as we like to call it,
to embedded chart builder.
So when you're building an
embedded chart for a
spreadsheet, it's a
little bit nicer.
I mean, I was fine with the way
before, but I'm sure there
was a good reason for these.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's like we have
all of these strongly typed
charts, like area chart,
bar chart.
Before, the embedded chart was
kind of just an ambiguous
chart with a collection
of options.
Now, you can cast it back into a
chart that you know and that
you've used before, and then use
some of the native methods
that are there on that chart.
IKAI LAN: That's true.
Although to be fair, there's
no reason set chart type
couldn't have done that
either, right?
Oh, actually, I think
you're right.
It is better this way.
ERIC KOLEDA: I think it
acts as the native
methods of that chart.
IKAI LAN: Right, right.
Whereas with set chart type,
you might not get
auto-complete if you needed
another method or something.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, just a little
syntactic sugar there.
IKAI LAN: Good things,
good things.
All right.
So I think those are
the big things.
There's a few more issues
that we've addressed.
So if you want to see the full
list of what went out these
last few weeks, go to
developers.googl
e.com/apps-script and click on
Release Notes, and you'll see
everything that we've
been doing.
Oh, wait, I'm sorry.
There was something else that
went out that we didn't put in
the Release Notes.
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, that's what
we're going to talk about
right now, right?
IKAI LAN: Let's talk
about it right now.
ERIC KOLEDA: And we're for sure
referring to the Cloud
SQL integration, right?
IKAI LAN: I am referring to
Cloud SQL integration.
ERIC KOLEDA: So that was just
announced yesterday.
It wasn't on our blog,
but the Cloud SQL
blog included it there.
Essentially as Ikai mentioned
before, Cloud SQL is a
Google-hosted MySQL database.
And you're relying on Google
infrastructure, and you don't
have to worry about security.
Connections are all secured by
OAuth2, so it's really quite a
nice product.
And while we had the ability to
connect to SQL databases in
the past in App Script using the
JDBC service, you couldn't
connect to Cloud SQL.
Because it had that extra OAuth
layer, it just didn't
work via the normal means.
So we now have a separate
method in the JDBC class
called "get Cloud
SQL connection."
And what's great about this is
that it uses the user's OAuth.
You just have to click an
"I approve" dialogue.
But then you don't need to worry
about user names and
passwords if you
don't want to.
There's still the option to pass
in optional user name and
password to have fine-grained
controls configured within
your MySQL database.
But just to connect, all you
need to do is to have access
to that Google Cloud SQL
database in the APIs console,
and then you're good to go.
IKAI LAN: Right.
Cloud SQL has got a lot of
benefits when you want to use
it with something like
Apps Script, right?
Which is that prior to Cloud
SQL, you might want to have a
JDBC connection to your
SQL database.
Now, the problem is that you'd
have to put it somewhere which
is accessible via the
open internet.
And of course, you'd secure it
with a user name and password,
but still, it's like do I
really want to do this?
I don't know.
Now, that's not say that people
who are doing it now
aren't doing a great
job because--
ERIC KOLEDA: You just have
to be aware of the risks.
IKAI LAN: Exactly.
And with Cloud SQL you can
completely lock it down to
just Apps Script.
So if you're interested in
looking at this search for
Google Cloud SQL, you're going
to need to enable the Cloud
SQL service.
And once you've enabled it,
that's when you can go ahead
and start running Apps Script.
You do need to do this via the
Google API console first.
It's not just going to
work out of the box.
You can't expect to
get Cloud SQL
connection and have it work.
ERIC KOLEDA: There's a caveat to
the way that the Cloud SQL
connection works today
from Apps Script.
There's a limitation in that
whoever is the effective user
of your script, that's the
user whose docs you're
accessing or Gmail you're
accessing, whoever the script
is running as, that user
currently today needs to have
access directly to the Cloud
SQL database instance.
That means having access to
that APIs console project.
So if you have a script that's
published, that runs as you
the owner, and maybe it's
a web app, that's fine.
You are the owner.
It runs as you.
You have access.
We're good to go.
The problem comes when you want
to have a script that
runs as the user, where let's
say you publish a web app, and
you want to allow anybody in the
world to sign in, approve
your script, and then
run as them.
That means that each individual
person would need
to have access to the database
in order for this to work.
And obviously, you don't know
who these people are sometimes
ahead of time.
Or even an organization, it
could be difficult to give all
1,000 people in your
organization access.
So that limitation today makes
it so that it may not be
appropriate for all use cases.
So we talked a little bit more
about this This in our JDBC
documentation.
You can read about it there.
But it's just a caveat upfront
that the way it exists today,
it may not work for
all scenarios.
And we are looking at improving
this integration
going forward so that we can
really open it up to
even more use cases.
IKAI LAN: But there are
definitely benefits to having
a SQL database available.
We have a lot of persistence
options right now.
We've got SQL.
We've got Cloud SQL.
So if you're going to go with
the SQL family, definitely
consider Cloud SQL
as an option.
On top of those two, we have
ScriptDb, which it's more so
much with document database.
And I know we want to talk more
about that at some point
in a future show.
We also have user properties,
which are good for storing a
small amount of data, but it's
very, very easy to use.
And we have cache.
Don't store any important
data in the cache.
I cannot stress this enough.
ERIC KOLEDA: It goes away.
IKAI LAN: All the time.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's cache.
IKAI LAN: And of course, we have
spreadsheets, which have
all the benefits to having UI
functions and all the things
that spreadsheets can do.
So thank you for that.
Thank you for introduction.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, no problem.
IKAI LAN: So why don't
we go ahead.
We have a few minutes left.
So let's move to some of the
Q&A and some of the live
participants.
Is anyone on air?
We have
ERIC KOLEDA: Some guests.
IKAI LAN: We have a
couple of folks.
Hey, guys.
John, is that you?
Yup, I see him waving.
This is John Coffman from
Washington, DC.
He's not shy.
He just likes to participate
in the show.
But welcome.
Let's see who else is there.
I can't see who that is.
There's a box blocking
my view.
But if you want to say hi, just
jump in any time and say
how are you're doing.
Otherwise we're going to
move into the Q&A.
Let me refresh this page.
It looks like we have only one
right now, which is "Does a
deep integration Apps Script
into Google Docs, such as
triggers, custom context menu,
like with spreadsheets, is
this on the road map?"
Well, we don't publish
a roadmap.
But this is something that we're
thinking a lot about
because we saw how popular
it is to expose this in
spreadsheets, right?
To expose especially
the context menu.
So we're definitely looking
at different ways
that we can do this.
But this is something we're
thinking a lot about.
We've got nothing to announce
right now, and we don't have
anything to announce soon.
But keep an eye out
on our blog.
Watch the show every
once in a while.
Watch the show every week.
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, one of the
things that the project
manager of Apps Script-- who we
know very well-- is always
mentioning is that he
loves use cases.
Whenever someone says I want
something, he'll always ask
himself, well, why?
What does that do?
What does that open up?
What does that allow that you
can't do today, right?
So whenever you have a request,
if you want to know
what about this feature?
What about that?
Give us more background.
Let us know how that could open
up new possibilities or
that there's a key script that
your company needs that that
could help you with.
And that'll really help us get
the context we need to decide
how to build a feature, how
important it is, and those
kind of activities.
IKAI LAN: One thing, for
instance, that comes to my
mind, and people have definitely
come to me with
this question, is well, a lot of
companies do things-- they
have what's called a workflow.
So you want to work on
something, and I have to
approve it because I
don't trust you.
I'm kidding.
We do have a code review
process here at Google.
So whenever we write code, it
has to be approved by at least
one more person before
it can be pushed out.
And this is true of
documentation, too.
So we understand
this use case.
So one thing a lot of people
want to do is they might want
to have a Google Doc.
And when you write a
doc, you might want
to send it for approval.
Well, right now, how
would you do this?
Well, you'd probably copy
and paste the URL,
put it in an email.
I don't want to say
it's clunky.
I mean, this is what probably
100% of people are doing is
right now, right?
Or you do share or something,
and there's not
a lot you can do.
Now, wouldn't it be really cool
if you had a menu that
said send for approval, check
approval status, there's a
little UI that tells you
what's going on.
Then your manager's manager or
whoever is reviewing has a
dashboard of all the
approval statuses.
I mean, this is what we talk
about when we say,
what's your use case?
What problem are you
trying to solve?
You let us know, and we will
figure out how to make this
work for you, if it's
legitimate.
ERIC KOLEDA: We want to give you
the tools you need to do
useful things.
That's why we're here, right?
IKAI LAN: Exactly.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yes, so I think
this falls in that category,
and we're going to continue to
look at it, but we don't have
any road map to announce.
IKAI LAN: Does anyone
on the live
show want to say anything?
Do you want to say hi, or do you
guys have any questions?
Uh-oh.
Hold on.
We've got to turn
your audio up.
JOHN COFFMAN: Did you
check the chat?
ERIC KOLEDA: Here we go.
IKAI LAN: The chat.
We need to check the chat.
JOHN COFFMAN: Did you
check the chat?
ERIC KOLEDA: Unfortunately, we
don't have the chat loaded up
on our laptops in front of us.
IKAI LAN: Maybe we should--
we've got to find a way to
disable that chat because--
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, some people
like the chat, though.
We probably should just join.
IKAI LAN: It's too many
options, though.
ERIC KOLEDA: Could you read
what's in the chat?
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
Hold on.
I can't hear you right
now, sorry.
Oh, I think you're muted.
JOHN COFFMAN: The reason
I don't talk much
is my mic is crappy.
IKAI LAN: Oh, your mic
sounds fine to me.
JOHN COFFMAN: When you're
talking about the deep
integration with Word--
two weeks ago we talked about
that for Forms as well.
So let me just bring
it up again that
that would be super.
IKAI LAN: For Forms
in Google Groups?
JOHN COFFMAN: Because for
example, in the--
ERIC KOLEDA: No,
I think Forms.
JOHN COFFMAN: --when you
send out the form--
IKAI LAN: Forms!
I see.
JOHN COFFMAN: Yeah.
So when I send out the form, and
it's going to 40 different
people, it would be nice to be
able to check the spreadsheet
and tell them 20 have
already responded.
Or to send out the form and say,
OK, your particular form
has to deal with apples, and
so at the top, we have some
information about apples.
And for another person, their
query on the form has to do
with bananas, so I'd like to go
to the spreadsheet and put
my bananas information
at the top of that.
So the forms would be somewhat
customized for each person to
whom they're sent.
IKAI LAN: I see.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's
interesting, yeah.
I do remember talking about
Forms coming up in the past.
And I think one of the issues
there is that the way Forms is
built today, it doesn't
have any plugs, right?
There's no dynamic stuff
that happens.
It's kind of you just get the
form and you fill it out.
I think our answer in the past,
and you've probably
heard it from us before, has
been you can build your own
forms like UI apps, text boxes,
labels, submit buttons,
forms, data storage.
Obviously you don't want to
build it all from scratch, but
the ability is there.
And I think it's interesting
maybe to find what are some
points we can plug into Forms
that are simple and would open
up a lot of possibilities
without having to make all of
Forms turn into all
of UI app, right?
Where everything is
reconfigurable.
If there's some sort of middle
ground we could find, that may
be useful to look at.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, I mean, it's
also tough, because I can also
see why you would want
that ability.
Because on the one hand, anyone
who's a developer can
easily put together a form with
information they want.
But now, you want to roll this
out to your non-developers and
give them a tool that's as
easy to use as Google
Spreadsheet's Forms where it's
not exactly drag-and-drop, but
it's kind of like
click-and-type.
So it's pretty good.
It's easy to use,
easy to set up.
But I don't know.
I wonder does it get too
complex at some point?
Forms already has some branching
functionality.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, there's
like, if you answer this
question, then go to this
page or skip that page.
IKAI LAN: But I've always
found-- and maybe this is just
the way my brain works, which is
visual programming is very
hard, you know, defining
logic like that.
For instance, there's that
Android project that's owned
by MIT that lets you program
Android Apps like putting
puzzles together.
And I was doing this, and I'm
going, this is harder than
actually programming.
Like it didn't make
any sense, but--
ERIC KOLEDA: As a programmer,
I guess.
It's probably harder.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
I can see what-- but there's
a point where it
does get too complex.
ERIC KOLEDA: Thanks for
the feedback, though.
But, yeah, I think we couldn't
just turn on like complete
manipulation of everything
dynamically, based on--
I think that could be a bit
challenging to even enable if
we wanted to, if we made
that a full-time--
IKAI LAN: What is cool is that
Spreadsheets does have a
get-form URL, an API call.
So depending on what it is
people need to do, there could
be multiple spreadsheets,
emailing, different links
depending on the user, but there
are limitations with
that solution as well.
But there are ways of creating
this sort of
thing with Apps Script.
So John, was there anything
else in chat?
I'm asking because we have
about a minute left.
JOHN COFFMAN: Nope, that's it.
Thanks, guys.
IKAI LAN: No problem.
I saw your comment "When are we
going to have a Hackathon
in Washington, DC.?" I've got
to give you the "nothing to
announce." But we are thinking
about doing some
stuff in New York City.
So hopefully, that's
not too far.
JOHN COFFMAN: No,
that's great.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, so we'll see
what we can do because these
are a very popular.
I want to do one in New York
City, but everyone was like,
oh, we always do them
in New York City.
But that was like two
years ago, right?
A year ago, two years ago.
I mean, I think we're due.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, why not?
IKAI LAN: Yeah, we've got
a good office there.
JOHN COFFMAN: You can do it
in my living room, and
I'll buy the pizza.
ERIC KOLEDA: He'll eat
a whole pie, though.
I don't know if that's
sustainable.
IKAI LAN: I'm very jealous--
JOHN COFFMAN: And Diet Coke.
IKAI LAN: --you can fit 60
people in your living room.
Yeah, OK.
Well, listen.
Just stay tuned and watch the
blog, and we'll definitely
post if we have more
external events.
JOHN COFFMAN: Super.
Thanks, guys.
IKAI LAN: No problem.
So I think that's about it.
ERIC KOLEDA: That does
it for today.
IKAI LAN: That does
Oh, I forgot.
I totally forgot to plug
something that's happening
next week, and I should have
done this in the beginning.
ERIC KOLEDA: Go for it.
IKAI LAN: Which is next
Thursday, we're having a very
special show, which is we're
going to be talking about
using Google Analytics
with Apps Script.
I'm going to be back at the
mother ship in Mountain View
to take care of a
couple things.
But when I'm on the West Coast
I've roped in one of my
friends who's on the Google
Analytics team.
He wrote the very popular blog
post about using Google
Analytics with Google
Apps Script.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's
been so popular.
IKAI LAN: And we're going
to have a show.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's perfect.
IKAI LAN: Talk about
doing that stuff.
And we are also going to have
"Office Hours." It's going to
take place next Wednesday
at 3:30 PM Eastern.
Whereas the other show, the
Analytics show is Thursday at
I believe it's 2:30
PM Pacific time.
So if time zones are confusing
you right now, go to
developers.google.com/live and
just look for the event.
It's called "Making Sense of
your Analytics," or something.
Anyway, it's next Thursday.
Look for it.
There's a couple of shows
going on that day.
ERIC KOLEDA: It's exciting.
IKAI LAN: And I'm excited to
try doing this show from a
different studio.
I'm curious-- you know New York
City, West Coast, what
the differences are there.
ERIC KOLEDA: East Coast,
West Coast?
IKAI LAN: East Coast,
West Coast.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right,
we'll figure it out.
IKAI LAN: Anyway, thank you
guys are joining us.
And if not joining us live,
thank you guys for watching
this whole thing.
We try to keep it fun
for you guys.
Until next time, I'm Ikai Lan.
ERIC KOLEDA: And I'm
Eric Koleda.
IKAI LAN: All right.
Bye guys.
ERIC KOLEDA: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]